about your relationship with dick fangio
now that the game's over can you at
least sympathize i guess in what he had
to deal with the last 24 to 48 hours or
is it too soon for that
yeah look i i think it's tough for for
all the you know
the
this is a challenging year i i i felt
bad for the cardboard fans
you know it is what it is
i can usually say you know it's been the
most eventful 24 hours
of my life
but you know when i got the call it was
you know pure excitement you know of
course there was nerves and
disbelief but
you know the encouragement the things
gave me and
you know guys
guys just keeping me up the whole time
it's
they made it a lot easier for me
[Music]
and he was what one of nine with two
interceptions kendall hinton's coming in
playing quarterback they had all every
single one of their quarterbacks that
were out because of the whole coveted
restriction stuff so they end up
starting a wide receiver at the
quarterback position sean payton though
if you're looking for somebody to make
excuses i don't feel like sean payton's
probably the guy
man we've been around this game a long
time and this is probably the strangest
thing that i've ever seen i mean the
fact that all the quarterbacks was out
and you had to go and get a guy
off the practice squad or whatever
wherever he was at and allow him a wide
receiver to play quarterback in the
national football league there's not
another quarterback that you could have
gone out and gotten
this this was a really strange thing
jack i i just um
i don't think sean payton really
empathize with anyone like you said hey
everybody's going through it this is a
tough situation but the one thing i can
say about the saints they took care of
business they didn't go in there and was
playing around with these guys they went
in there they knew that that team was
weak and they just they just blew them
out and that's what you're supposed to
do against teams like that you look at
taysom hill he didn't have a big big um
week or anything like that i mean he
threw one interception he had two i
think he had two rush um tds but he
played solid and you know you look at
the young guy i mean that's just unfair
to expect kendall hidden to go out there
and be able to have success against who
i think is one of the top defenses if
not the best defense in the league
100 100 i have so much respect for sean
payton though like sean payton's just
like okay no drew brees uh who we going
to go with the quarterback we're going
to take some hill and then we're going
to adapt the offense now taysom hill
becomes like this great running back in
the red zone creating all this new
offense and adapting the offense like he
seems to be like somebody that no matter
what you do no matter who you take away
from him the only thing he's thinking is
when and he continues to win and win and
win somebody else who is like that is
kyle shanahan kyle shanahan has no
business continuing to win football
games right now he's one he's lost every
star player seemingly on his whole
roster and he just keeps getting it done
here he was on his star receiver debo
samuel after a big one
i can't tell you how good divo was today
i mean it's just i always mess with them
because
i'm a very soft compliment type of guy
i
would never you've never arrived you
always get better so diva's got a lot to
work on um but he's one of the best
football players i've been around i mean
it doesn't matter how good it is or how
good it looks he's going to get it done
um some of those plays that he made in
the first half i mean the big run that
he had on the same run that he had last
time um just the physicality he plays
with being able to go to him and that's
all we were trying to do there in the
last drive just especially to get in the
field goal range just throw a quick one
to devo um and he came through every
single time and the way he blocked the
way he ran uh the other time he got down
there got a field goal i think in the
third quarter i mean started off with
the six yard throw where diva ran
through some people so i love that guy
and um but he's got to still keep
getting a lot better at everything else
hey i love depot samuel but i i really
love kyle shanahan i think he's done a
terrific job i mean you think about him
losing star defensive players offense
guys his quarterback and never making
excuses just focus on the next game
making sure that his guys are prepared
and ready to go it's been a really tough
year on him but you see he's staying
positive and he's got those guys still
flying around playing they're right
there in the mix they're five and six
and arizona is gonna probably eventually
drop out of that seventh spot
don't trust minnesota chicago they're a
bunch of frauds san francisco is sitting
right there nobody's really paying
attention to them they can run the ball
they're still physical and you know jack
you talk about if you had let me ask you
this if you had uh opportunity
who would you take if you had a choice
to pick two coaches who are the two top
coaches in the national football
national football league you
believe wow so i just gotta get anybody
that's a heck any any two coaches just
i'm because you know who i'm taking i'm
taking belichick and i'm taking kyle
shanahan
andy reid pretty tough to pass up sean
payton pretty tough to pass up i i hear
you though i mean sean mcvay pretty
tough to pass up you start going through
the list so hard to choose just two
i it's so much respect for andy reid
right now it's it's hard though to say
how much is it is patrick mahomes how
much of it is andy reid we know how much
it is we know we know that hold on jack
we know that it's a lot of patrick
mahomes because he had donovan mcnabb he
had other players michael vick and he
wasn't reaching this level of success so
we know the quarterback is the key we
know that because aaron um andy reid is
the same guy but he has different
weapons he's got that quarterback he's
got that centerpiece and he's got the
best player in the national football
league now we can elevate it but what
i'm saying with kyle shanahan you
imagine if kyle shanahan had
patrick mahomes and the weapons that he
has debo samuel and all those guys i
just
i give a lot of props to kyle shannon i
just think he's done a wonderful job
yeah i i couldn't agree with you more
but andy reid i don't i don't know that
he was at the same level i'll give you
that but he certainly didn't suck when
he had mike vick and had donovan mcnabb
he was just always this close and
couldn't break through you know that
final barrier uh but that's that's tough
here here's speaking of tough so now san
francisco has this they can't play at
home they can't even practice at home
santa clara there's no contact sports
in the county so now they're basically
gonna have to move to arizona let's just
see let's let's let's go back to
shanahan real quick here is shanahan
on everything that's unfolding with no
contact sports and how they found out
this is some crazy stuff right here
for us to be heading out here
yesterday and the relationship we have
with them and for all of our players and
coaches and everyone on that plane and
our wives to find that out while we're
getting on a plane um and no one to tell
us i mean it was just extremely
disappointing um i got a lot of guys
here who
um we can handle anything and we
understand how big of a deal this virus
is and we are it's why we're so
committed and we feel that's why
um
so we feel like we've done it as good as
we can and not only protected ourselves
but also really protected our community
um and for
you know that's why we think we would
love to stay in our hometown um where
our fans want us and
playing in levi's with no people there
and only people that have been tested
every single day for the last five
months and
i get it they made that decision and we
got to deal with it um
but for them for to find that out
through a tweet or a press conference
where
i have an entire plane coming up to me i
have all wives everyone's girlfriends
everyone's family members kids
saying that what they heard there we can
be gone for the entire month of december
are we going to be quarantined for 14
days when we get back i mean that's all
we could talk about for the last 18
hours
because we got no answers from them and
i was just very disappointed and
very proud of our guys
that i couldn't give them the answers
and they could put it to the side and
come out and play like that i got so
much appreciate appreciation for our
team and those players and
um i'm very proud to be this guy's coach
well let's start with the obvious this
is an impossible situation here i mean
this is like you have to take them away
to football camp or something it's like
going to training camp back in the old
days they're going to have to transport
not mid-season towards the end of the
season when they're finally starting to
put the pieces back together here
take the whole band on the road go to
arizona set up shoplight and do rent
some dormitories like where are they
gonna sleep where they're gonna live and
not to get too practical not to get too
literal but when he was saying that he
had all of their wives and girlfriends
hitting him up like do you think he has
like they all have shanahan's number i
was i was a little confused by that like
when they were getting ready to play a
football game and he was still on the
airplane or is he saying that all the
players were talking to his wives and
girlfriends and then bringing those
messages back to shanahan that was the
only one that caught me a little
sideways
yeah i didn't know if the wives and
girlfriends and the family members were
on the plane with the players on the
plane with the players or what the
situation was but it's it is a very um
dicey situation because you know you
want you want to be able to be at your
home situation you want to be able to
practice and be able to be at your own
facilities and and have that comfort
level and when you when you can't be
comfortable then that anxiety um kind of
creeps in and you're you're worried
you're worried about your family and you
can't it's hard to play football like
that but like he said he's really proud
of the way the players responded it just
shows a tremendous amount of mental
toughness but also
the way he's conducted himself in the
midst of this situation because a lot of
times the players are looking at the
coach and how will the coach respond
what stand is he taking and then the
players will follow suit but this is a
mentally tough team i mean to go through
what they've gone through this entire
year all the injuries all that adversity
and for them to be in a position where
they can still make the playoffs after
losing both and their quarterbacks and
all these other guys and it's good to
see richard sherman back making plays
um pretty special pretty special
regardless if they go to the super bowl
if they make the playoffs if they don't
the bottom line is this is a special
year and they will always remember this
year because of the way they've dealt
with this
and look at the amount of respect that
it's given you for kyle shanahan with
the way he's dealt with it and i feel
the same way about that i mean he's like
he's got that he's got that same
character to him where it doesn't matter
what you take away all he is thinking
about is win and he's able to go win
like mullins comes in and if you're a
football fan that's been following the
league for a while you know that you
should still have confidence in the san
francisco 49ers that's a rare thing
that's a rare rare thing a lot of teams
roll over let the other team pet their
belly this is a different kind of coach
this is a different kind of team
same token it's not sugar coated nfl
right now is at a crossroads you have
baltimore who's trying to play on
tuesday night football after they were
going to be playing on thanksgiving and
now they're saying it's going to be on
wednesday night football now you have
all the players going wait a minute
we're not going to play we don't have a
quarterback we don't have our best tight
end we're missing about 90 of our roster
it feels like and you still want us to
go play a football game wait and it's
always dangerous if you're going to put
somebody between their check and their
health and those are those are dicey
dicey situations and that's now where
we're getting to so this is a big week
this is a big night for the national
football league we'll see what kind of a
resolution that we come to
the the raiders speaking of a big night
the raiders had been getting hot they
had been trending in the right direction
they go to atlanta maybe they got a
little cocky here as their head coach
after a tough
loss during the week you pushed back
pretty hard on this idea that this six
and four teams felt a different than it
did last season or anything you were
talking about finishing it do you have
any did you have any feeling that maybe
his team bought too much into that no no
no you know it's going to be written and
talked about i'm sure on you know some
of the talk shows rightfully so
um we didn't play well today falcons are
fighting for their lives we said that
coming in here this is one of the best
three and seven teams i have seen they
did this to minnesota
who was a playoff team last year
and
i challenge anybody that's uh getting
ready for atlanta this team is a very
good football team and are well coached
and a big part of that too is rahim
morris i think he was on john gruden's
staff and you know he had these guys
ready to play and this is kind of the
atlanta team that we expected it's not
the raider team that we expected because
you know the raiders got comfortable
they let their guard down and when you
play you beat kansas city early in the
year and then you play them a couple
weeks ago and you you look pretty good
plant them then all of a sudden you you
come out to atlanta and you completely
forget how to play football and we see
that we saw some things that we hadn't
really seen this year
from the raiders whether it was
josh jacobs inability to run the
football
two fumbles derek carr fumble pick six
darren waller
i don't know what's going on with him i
mean it's just like he wasn't into it
the offensive line it was just like
everybody was kind of lazy thinking that
they could just show up and that they
were going to win the football game so
i look at john gruden and i like him
he's an old school coach and he
understands that hey this is one game it
wasn't a great game we're going to look
for look at this game we're going to
learn from it and we're going to move on
and that's the type of coach that john
gruden is but he's got to get those guys
ready because young players have a the
you know the tendency to become
complacent and you don't want that
complacency kicking in toward the latter
part of the season
it's a good point this does happen in
the nfl and it can be a one week thing
and then it can be you know next week
they'll come out and look how they have
right they're you know they've been
looking good especially with a young
team we've talked about this we've
documented this with the raiders it's a
team that's really close but they're not
at the pinnacle yet it was a complete
rebuild right trade khalil mack trade
amari cooper load up on young talent and
now those young talent are one or two
years within the program but pretty soon
they're going to be three or four years
or five years within the program and
that to me is when they're gonna have
their chance to really make a playoff
push i think they're probably maybe two
or three maybe two years away from the
real reckoning day for the raiders if
you will
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports